this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit even if you
never cared for his songs you surely
have heard them he was a musical prodigy
the first real electric guitar hero he
grew from humble beginnings and a
fractured family to establish himself as
one of the most influential guitarists
of all time a major force in 20th
century music get ready to jam out on
your air guitar with today's protagonist
Jimi Hendrix
[Music]
Jimi Hendrix was born Johnny Allen
Hendrix on FM at the 27th 1942 in
Seattle his father Al later renamed him
James Marshall or Jimmy for short young
Jimmy descended from a family of
professional entertainers his
grandmother Norah Rose was a dancer with
a traveling vaudeville troupe called
Lacey's bands and her husband Bertrand
was a stagehand and roadie for the same
outfit by 1912 the traveling couple had
settled in Vancouver Canada and in 1919
they had their second born James Allen
or young al had inherited from Nora a
love of music and competitive dancing in
1941 al got engaged
Lucille gt-r lively and beautiful
sixteen year old from Roslyn Washington
they had met that very same year at a
concert featuring legendary jazz pianist
Fats Waller they were married the
following year and as we already know
they welcomes Johnny / Jimmy on the 27th
of November so is it important to note
that Jimmy Hendrix was called Johnny at
Birth and yes it is because it was a
symptom of Al and Lucille's fast
deteriorating relationship since their
engagement days Lucille had never let go
of what she loved the most partying and
enjoying the nightlife and she did party
hard eventually developing an alcohol
problem and psychiatric issues
Lucille also had developed a reputation
for being unfaithful amongst her alleged
lovers was one Johnny Williams
so when Johnny / Jimmy was born al was
stationed in the Pacific with the US
Army but at the end of World War two
when our return to Seattle from his
service he legally changed Johnny's name
so was Jimmy an illegitimate child well
that we don't know and neither did Al
but at least he wanted to erase any
possible link to a potential
extramarital affair by 1947 young
Jimmy's domestic life could be
accurately described as dysfunctional
Lucille was by all accounts a caring and
loving mother when she was there
unfortunately that was a rare occurrence
a drinking problem worsened and she
developed a penchant for simply
disappearing for days at a time
naturally this disappearing act led to
frequent violent raus between her now
but the couple they stuck together for
four more years and had even more
children together
Leon Joseph Kathy and finally Pamela
1951 in December of that same year Al
and Lucille finally separated and Al
took over custody of his children money
was always tight for the single father
Joseph Kathy and Pamela were all
assigned to foster families I'll take on
multiple jobs janitor gas station
attendant gardener and this allowed him
to look after Jimmy and Leon but even so
the two brothers spent much of the early
1950s under the care of relatives
friends or neighbors eventually I was
forced to foster his eldest sons too for
a brief period in 1953 al was able to
stabilize his financial situation and he
was granted custody of Jimmy once more
[Music]
Allen Jimmy's relationship may have been
closed or tense or both varying by which
account you read they surely did bond
over music from an early age Jimmy
developed a fascination for legendary
blues guitarists and vocalists in Al's
record collection artists like BB King
Muddy Waters Howlin wolf and most of all
the legendary Robert Johnson who had
learned his guitar skills after signing
a covenant with the devil at a
crossroads whose finger play was so
skillful that he sounded like two
guitarists playing at once and who died
at 27 after drinking a shot of poisoned
whiskey the fascination for blues guitar
would soon be noticed by Al with the
help of a broom you see Al Hendrix ran a
tight ship around the home and while he
was out he required Jimmy to keep his
bedroom tidy and clean when he returned
home he would often notice some broom
straw on Jimmy's bedroom floor in Al's
version of the story he discovered that
Jimmy would sit on his bed listening to
blues tracks while strumming on the
broom as if it were a guitar moved by
this passion al got Jimmy his first
instrument an old ukulele with one
string in a nother less warm version of
events al would beat Jimmy senseless
every time he returned home to find
straw on the floor whatever the truth
about their relationship al did
encourage his son's musical talents in
1957 al allowed Jimmy to graduate from
one string ukulele to full six string
acoustic guitar that he had bought for
$5 Jimmy had a keen musical ear and
immediately learned how to tune the
guitar and play songs smoke on the water
was still to come
so the first tune of choice for a novice
guitarist like Jimmy was Lois
by Richard Berry with its three chords a
D and E minor in the summer of 1958
Jimmy joined his first band The Velvet
owns the following year now got him his
first electric guitar a Supra Ozark
1560s a simple model with a single
pickup coil and an $89 price tag by
going electric Jimmy and The Velvet owns
could play their first concert even
though they were too young for the
nightclubs circuit
Jimmy could still hone his skills
playing teen dances in recreation halls
and housing projects bands hone his
skills he did so much so that he got his
first admirers and The Velvet urns
included in their dance sets his
original tune jimmy's blues jimmy's
reputation grew and in 1959 he was
invited to join another band the rocking
kings but he felt trapped in the small
scene of house parties and recreation
centers already aware of his potential
and the unique sounds that he was able
to create even at this early stage the
sound of his electric guitar had a
unique quality to it
thanks to a very practical reason as a
left-handed musician Jimmy could not
afford to buy a left-handed guitar so he
had to make do with secondhand standard
guitars for righties he made as
everything work by swapping the position
of the strings but he did not want to or
perhaps he wasn't able to flip the
position of the coils or pickups the
results the part of the coil designed to
pick up the notes from the chunky
strings was now amplifying the
vibrations from the thin strings and
vice versa the result was a signature
mix of bright high notes and delicate
low ones an opportunity arose for young
Jimmy in 1960 when he was invited to
join James Thomas and his Tomcats this
was a professionally managed band
specializing in higher-end venues like
military officers clubs soon Jimmy would
be spending more time with the officers
[Music]
Jimmy's childhood and household had been
unstable and fractured only slightly
mitigated by our strict discipline the
end results Jimmy he knew how to get
into trouble by 1960 Jimmy had dropped
out of Garfield High School according to
him he had been expelled for smart
mouthing a teacher in between gigs and
rehearsals Jimmy who was helping out
with his new landscaping business to
make an extra buck but it was never
enough to cover Jimmy's taste for
expensive and flashy clothing according
to some accounts he wasn't afraid to
steal to fund this lifestyle at minimum
Jimmy committed two felonies that we
know about on May the 2nd 1961 he took a
car without the owner's permission and
went on a joyride he did it again four
days later though it's not clear if it
was the same car at the end of the month
Hendrix joined the army probably as an
alternative to serving a jail sentence
later photos of Hendrix in old fashions
Victorian army tunics are iconic so it's
kind of strange to see Jimmy in the
standard US Army olive fatigues in June
of 1961 private Hendrix was dropping
push-ups at Fort Ord California before
being shipped to Fort Campbell Kentucky
training with the 101st Airborne
Division it was only at this stage that
al sent in his new guitar a Danelectro
bronze standard nicknamed Betty Jean
after his fiancee at the time Jimmy was
not the only musician at Fort Campbell
Billy Cox a bass player was able to spot
Jimmy's talents which he later described
as coming from a creative musical space
somewhere between Beethoven and John Lee
Hooker Cox and Hendrix hit it off and
formed new band the King casuals Jimmy
and Billy had the potential but the
casuals never went far as Jimmy burdens
by his constant cash flow problems which
frequently porn his guitar for a few
bucks Jimmy was a source of frustration
also for his superiors described as
being unable to conform to military
rules and regulations in later accounts
Hendrix reported that he had been
honorably discharged from the Army
because he had broken his ankle during a
parachute training jump but well that's
actually BS on July the 2nd 1962 Jimmy
was discharged with an undesirable
status nothing too dramatic his officer
simply noted that he was severely
distracted while performing duties due
to his
of thinking about his guitar ah drift
that sergeant realized he had just
written Jimi Hendrix's first recorded
review in addition to that appraisal the
other army medical documents report
Jimi's declaration that he was gay a
common stratagem used at the time to be
discharged early from the service after
his discharge
Jimi left Fort Campbell with $400 in his
pockets after selling Betty Jeanne's who
an army buddy the guitar not his
girlfriend that is he collected his
final army wages and moved to
Clarksville Tennessee settling around a
jazz bar that he liked a lot he liked it
so much in fact that he spent three
hundred eighty four dollars in a single
night which is almost three thousand
three hundred dollars in today's money
stranded in Tennessee all Jimi could do
was return to Fort Campbell and beg his
friends to return him the danelectro
with his trusty six strings Jimmy was
able to make a few bucks playing solo
gigs and sustain himself until Billy Cox
finished his service in September two
things of note here one it seems like
Jimmy was in no rush to return to Billy
gene the girlfriend that is not the
guitar and two there are no recorded
traces of the Danelectro after September
1962 so it may still be in Clarksville
if you hail from there start looking for
it now as it would probably fetch over a
hundred thousand dollars at auction
[Music]
by September 1962 bass player Billy Cox
had also left the army billy and jimmy
reassembled the King casuals and set
their sights on one of the capital
cities of American music Nashville
very soon the casuals became the kings
of the black nightclub scene in
Nashville supporting touring soul stars
like the Marvelettes or Curtis
Mayfield's things were looking up at
Jimmy and he was even able to afford
train tickets to visit grandma Nora the
vaudeville dancer in Vancouver this
happens around Christmas of 1963 during
a stay in Canada Hendrix joins a local
bands for a short tour which ends in the
attention of early rock and roll icon
Little Richard Lizza Richard a hard him
as a session guitarist in his band
touring and recording with the legend he
can be heard on the single I don't know
what you've got but it's got me during
1964 1965 Jimmy became a sought-after
session musician playing recording
studios from New York to Los Angeles one
of his best-known records of the time is
testified by the i'li brothers and early
energetic funk piece where Jimmy at
first displays is lead guitar shops on
vinyl during this period Hendrix became
infatuated with Luther fain pre-dawn a
former lover of king of soul Sam Kirk
who was well-connected to the New York
black music scene the infatuation was
reciprocal with Luther fain or Fay
describing him as skinny raw bones over
facts underfed looking Hendricks was my
type Jimmy and Fay had a passionate
affair in which pre-dawn embodied the
role of both Muse and mentor introducing
him to influential soul and R&B
musicians however from her point of view
they were never really a couple and
certainly not in an exclusive
relationship
Jimmy was insanely jealous of her but
eventually he had to accept the fact
that this cute little heartbreaker could
never be all his in late 1965 Jimmy had
settled in the Greenwich Village
District of New York he had formed a new
ensemble Jimmy James and the blue flames
with whom he played in various
nightclubs it was at the cheetah Club in
1966 that he was spotted by a British
model CUDA Linda Keith's girlfriend of
Rolling Stones guitarist Keith Richards
Linzer invited Jimmy to a party and
discovered that though he may have
displayed the bravado and confidence of
a guitar hero while on stage Ray
Jimmy was shy polite afflicted by low
self-esteem and in need of a good meal
Linda immediately realized Jimmy star
potential and badly wanted to help him
she loans him one of Keith Richards
guitars which was a white Fender
Stratocaster she then invited a series
of influential managers and producers to
listen to Hendrix play first it was
Andrew Oldham manager for Rolling Stones
but that night Jimi's performance was
lackluster then it was producer Seymour
Stein who later discovered Madonna this
time Jimmy was in much better form
overcome with enthusiasm and sheer rock
badassery the guitarist smashed Keith
Richards white fender onto the stage
Linda was so furious with Jimmy that
Stein fled the club not keen on getting
involved in the row third time was the
lucky one when Linzer invited chasse
Chandler to attend yet another gig at
the Cafe Wha Chandler was the bass
player with the animals now turns
manager he agreed with Linda that Jimmy
was a full-on rock star just waiting to
be launched Chaz convinced Jimmy to fly
with him to London where he would quit
the animals and manage the guitarists
budding career on September the 23rd
1966 the bassist and the guitarist they
took off from New York headed to England
it was mid flight that chasse proposed a
new spelling for his clients stage name
and Jimi Hendrix was born now if you've
got a budding music career or something
else you want to get out into the world
well a great way to do that would be
with today's sponsor Squarespace now two
simple things maybe you've got some idea
for a website or a business or a YouTube
channel or a podcast and knocking around
in your head well - the only way to
figure out whether that's worth doing is
to get it out there to the world and
that could be a bit daunting because
obviously it's scary to go and pursue
new things but not knowing how to set up
a website is no excuse there are no
excuses available with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to you want to sell something online yes
easy to set up a store with Squarespace
want to do a podcast start a YouTube
channel well your want websites to
complement those and indeed you can
actually have a podcast site with
Squarespace it'll start on Squarespace
with a beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or you
can start from scratch or you can move
over from an existing domain making
everything super
easy to manage don't start from scratch
though use a template don't have any
excuses
now once you've gone through the easy
customization process there are no
updates there are no patches there's no
tech PS to deal with no one likes that
stuff and Squarespace also handle all of
the website he stuff podcasts like I
said yes mailing lists yes social
integrations oh yes and much more just
go get started now it's easy just go do
it also 24/7 customer support in case
you get stuck but you probably won't
head to Squarespace comm for a free
trial when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /pi graphics and you'll
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain let's get back to it
[Music]
once in London Chandler organised
auditions to form Jimmy's band settling
on a power trio format whereby Jimmy
would cover both guitar and lead vocal
duties the slots are filled by guitarist
nor reading who was reluctantly put on
bass and a well wins of a drummer called
Mitch Mitchell Chandler also enlisted
help from the animal zone manager
Michael Jeffery as he was more business
savvy Jeffery was later described as a
sketchy type with alleged ties to
organized crime in Newcastle northern
England and even to the secret services
under Geoffrey's guidance the band was
christened the Jimi Hendrix Experience
and immediately set to work on a record
before the album could be released Jimi
was as ever strapped for cash and in
need of playing small gigs it was at one
of these semi-improvised sessions that
Chandler introduced him to DJ an
hairdresser Kathy Etchingham it took
Jimmy one pickup line I think you are
beautiful a couple of hours later they
were spending the night in Jimmy's hotel
the next morning they were awakened by
another of Jimmy's many lovers mad with
jealousy the unnamed lady threatened to
smash Hendrix as only guitar on his hand
the early morning drama did not deter
Kathy who became Jimi's regular
girlfriends in London she stuck by him
during the recording sessions of the
experiences debut album while they led a
simple and quiet life playing Monopoly
and twister and eating mashed potatoes
Jimmy Nolt and Mitch released their
debut single a cover of hey Joe a track
that deserves its own buy graphics
episode the next single was an original
Hendrix tune one that would introduce
the world to his pyrotechnic lead guitar
as well as his songwriting talent and
it's Purple Haze the success of these
singles granted the Jimi Hendrix
Experience a slot at the Monterey
international Pop Festival in California
the power trio took to the stage on June
the 18th 1967 unleashing on the audience
a barrage of original tunes and covers
that literally set the stage on fire
Rolling Stone wrote an orgasmic
explosion of singing feedback agitated
stretches of jazzy improvisation and a
recombinants R&B guitar Hendrix egged on
by nor Redding and Mitch Mitchell's
rhythmic frenzy drove Wild Thing
head-on into a wall of white noise at
the end of a heavily distorted Wren
of wildling by the Troggs Jimmy set his
guitar on fire before smashing it to
bits on the stage the Jimi Hendrix
Experience became impossible to ignore
[Music]
the first LP of the trio are you
experienced hit the record stores in
August of 1967 the music critics initial
response was unenthusiastic this is how
Rolling Stones summarized their review
of the album despite Jimi's musical
brilliance and the group's total
precision the poor quality of the songs
and the inanity of the lyrics to often
get in the way above all this record is
unrelentingly violence and lyrically in
artistically violence at that not
everyone agreed many appreciated Jimi's
alchemists brew of psychedelia 12 bar
blues hard rock and aggressive funk are
you experienced went on to spend one
hundred and six weeks on the Billboard
200 eventually selling more than five
million copies in the United States
alone Jimi's debut was packed with many
of his greatest works songs impossible
to ignore even if you don't really dig
Hendrix hey Joe Purple Haze manic
depression the wind cries Mary red house
and of course foxy lady Jimi Hendrix is
routinely praised for his lead guitar
work is imaginative fast lengthy solos
but foxy lady is a clear example of
Jimi's powerful rhythm guitar plank in
other words the chords and riffs that
make the backbone of a song and the
hallmark of a good songwriter the main
riff a foxy lady heard in the verses and
during the solo section is deceptively
simple it alternates a low F sharp with
a high and a creating a funky bouncy
effect but it revolves around a complex
court f-sharp 7th to the 9th the chord
so distinctive that it became known as
the Hendrix chord lyrically speaking the
song is about one cute little
heartbreaker a sweet little love maker a
lady who Jimmy says got to be mine or
mine although never confirmed by Hendrix
himself the foxy lady is almost
certainly his lover from the early days
of New York Bay Pitt gone or washy
another obvious candidate is Kathy
Etchingham who claims to have inspired
Jimi's the wind cries Mary one night
Jimmy accused Cathy smash of being too
lumpy the couple had a furious Rao
ending with Cathy leaving their
apartments Jimmy saddened by her
departure composed his most famous bass
the couple reconciled almost immediately
and decided to go steady from then on
throughout 1967 and until the end of
1968 but their love was still fragile
threatens on all sides by the trappings
of fame after the success of are you
experienced Hendrix was a global
superstar with all the benefits and
added precious history I was expected to
tour and record constantly abiding to an
exhausting schedule in early January the
experience was touring Sweden when on
the 10th of January Jimmy who was
reportedly checking in at the Gothenburg
Police Headquarters apparently on
charges of possession of illegal
substances it was clear to everyone in
his entourage that Hendrix was not a
stranger to illicit drugs but in 1968
his consumption escalated from marijuana
to LSD amphetamines and heroin Cathy
knows it out during this period Jimi's
normally sweet character started to
change becoming aggressive with his
friends and even smashing up hotel rooms
according to Cathy Jimi's entourage was
inflated by dodgy undesirable people
with an aggressive edge to them
scroungers best and possibly drug
dealers or criminal types Cathy
described how he started to look really
rough his hair was breaking off he
didn't have healthy skin he looked as if
it aged ten years in two-and-a-half
Kathy Etchingham decided she had to move
on and the couple split up in 1969 all
the drama in the background did not
prevent the experience from delivering
two albums in 1968 access bold as love
and Electric Ladyland rolling stone via
reviewer Jim Miller continued to show
its aversion for Jimmy on Miller
acknowledges the album as a vortex of
apocalyptic transcendence
he writes off the songs as basically a
bore the follow-up record Electric
Ladyland is widely considered Jimi's
masterpiece even Rolling Stone was more
generous in its review the album is
noteworthy because of its production
history several rock stars of the era
collaborated on it from Stevie Winwood
z-- to Brian Jones while Hendrix himself
continued his experiments with recording
technology using loops tapes and phasing
effects Hendrix actually left the
recording studio unsatisfied with the
final sound of the recording he was even
less impressed with cover imposed by the
label a photo featuring a group of naked
women which was banned from many record
stores Jimi's initial pick was a photo
of him and
and playing with some children taken by
Linda Eastman soon to become mrs. Paul
McCartney the experience immediately
started touring to promote lady lands
amidst growing tensions fueled by
Jimmy's addiction problems and Redding's
growing dissatisfaction with his bass
guitar duties and yet they were still
wildly successful on March the 22nd 1969
Billboard magazine reported them winning
the 1969 popular music prize awarded at
the festival to saw in Paris the same
issue listed the experience as the
second best-selling band in the US
bested only by Simon & Garfunkel but
trouble was always behind the corner
after a tour in Canada in May Jimi was
tried and fined for possession of
narcotics in Toronto shortly afterward
on the 29th of June no reading decided
to call it quits after a show in Denver
the Jimi Hendrix Experience had
officially disbanded the breakup did not
deter Jimi though he got back in touch
with his old army buddy bassist Billy
Cox with the trusty Mitch Mitchell on
drums guitarist Jerry fellows and
percussionist Juma Sultan they assembled
a new band gypsy Sun and rainbows the
new band ravished audiences and ravaged
a few eardrums at possibly the rock
concert par excellence the Woodstock
Festival on the evening of August the
18th 1969 Jimi and friends took to the
stage performing classics and new tracks
alike even if you're not into this kind
of music
yeah probably have heard Jimi's
rendition of the star-spangled banner
this mangled electrocuted version of the
u.s. national anthem could be considered
Jimi's most political moment sonic
commentary on a nation divided by civil
unrest and the debate on the Vietnam War
shortly afterwards stock Jimi was
involved in one of the most puzzling
events of his life the story comes from
drug dealer and mobster John Roberts one
of his many unsavory friends in New York
one night Jimmie had ventured into town
looking to buy some cocaine as he
entered a club frequented by dealers he
was spotted by two Italian American
young men described by Robert says
wiseguy wannabes the two saw an occasion
to make some serious money and they
kidnapped him they held him in captivity
for two days during which time they
contacted his management
asking for either a ransom in cash or a
stake in royalties from future records
in one version of the event manager
Michael Jeffrey sent a group of thugs
armed with machine guns to free Jimmy in
a less spectacular account it was Robert
suit solve the case using his underworld
contacts he quickly identified the two
kidnappers and threatened them over the
phone you let Jimmy go or you aren't
dead do not harm a hair of his afro the
two wise guys relented and a week later
Roberts retaliated by giving them the
beating of their life apparently Jimmy
had been so stoned he barely took notice
of the whole ordeal Jeffery insisted
that he get back to work immediately but
not with the Gypsy Sun rainbows instead
he suggested that Jimmy reform a power
trio as this was more popular and more
profitable
Jimmy was clearly not happy as he
preferred larger ensembles which allowed
for more experimentation improvisation
the following stints with Billy Cox and
buddy Mars ended with a disastrous
concert at the Madison Square Garden in
New York on January the 28th 1970
played only two songs before he sat down
on the stage and refused to continue
despite buddy's best efforts Jimmy
unplugged his guitar and walked
backwards Mars Cox and Hendrix parted
ways in the aftermath
Jimmy later told Rolling Stone about his
exhaustion resulting from internal
conflict I think of the Madison Square
Garden is like the ends of a big long
fairy tale which is great I think it's
like the best ending I could possibly
have come up with
[Music]
the following month saw Jimmy partially
reunite with the original experienced
lineup for some jams and recording
sessions but nothing concrete
materialized
he was also preoccupied with more
personal matters on March the 9th 1970
news got to him that ex-girlfriend Cathy
had just married in a desperate attempt
winner bag Jimmy flew from New York to
London the next day and implored her to
leave her husband Ryan moved to New York
with him
Hendricks a shorter that he had rid
himself of all of his bad habits and his
bad influences but it was futile he had
realized far too late that Cathy was the
love of his life and he had lost her to
a life without love Jimmy remained in
Europe until September and having
reformed the experience once again with
Cox on bass instead of reading they had
even played an important gigs the Isle
of Wight Festival on August 30th on
September the 17th he was back in London
and he spent the night with his latest
lover German painter Monika Dannemann
the morning after she found Jimmy
unconscious in his bed having choked on
his vomit while asleep he was rushed to
some Mary Abbas Hospital where he was
pronounced dead at 11:45 a.m. on
September the 18th 1970 the police found
that he might have overdosed on sleeping
pills which caused his accidental death
but not everybody agrees Eric Burdon
vocalist of the animals and war was the
last to perform with Jimmy at a jam
session on the 16th burdened claims that
after his death he had found a poem
written by Hendrix in Monica's apartment
according to him the poem was intended
both as Jimmy's spiritual last will and
testament as well as his suicide note
burden did not produce the note at the
inquest leading to the death being ruled
accidental
another more sinister theory came to
light in June of 2009 after the
publication of rock roadie by James tap
he writes one of the stars roadies tapi
right Sal one year after Jimmy's death a
drunken Michael Jeffrey had confessed to
murdering the guitarist in some
accomplices had forced down his throat
sleeping bills alongside two entire
bottles of red wine the motive Geoffrey
had taken out a life-insurance policy
worth two million dollars on Jimmy
Hendrix the star had become too
unreliable to tour and record profitably
he was now worth more by being dead
rather than alive Geoffrey never told
the story to anybody else dying in a
plane crash in 1973 conspiracy maybe
that maybe there's a kernel of truth a
doctor on duty at the time of Jimmy's
death told The Telegraph that Hendrix
had a stomach full of red
but no alcohol in his blood evidence
that he had died immediately after
swallowing the drink with no time to
metabolize it I'll let you draw your own
conclusions whatever caused Jimi Hendrix
left this world too early aged only 27
like his idol Robert Johnson like many
other rock stars of his age he was too
long a victim of the schemers of greedy
managers since the demands and pressures
of Fame luckily for all of us this
legacy did not melt into the sea like a
castle made of sand so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe also
please do check it off fantastic sponsor
Squarespace who are linked to below and
thank you for watching
[Music]